[music]
>> The master key for the hour.
Allah says in Surah Al Imran chapter
number three verse number
chapter number 60. Surah Al Imran
chapter number three verse number 64.
1 2 3 4
5 Oh, sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
Really sorry. Sorry. Really sorry.
Sorry.
Really sorry. Uh, 10. Uh
Sorry. Sorry. It's not there in the
translation.
>> [laughter]
>> Allah says in Surah Al Imran chapter
number three verse number 64.
1 2 3 4 5 6 Even brother Imran Fazal is
raising. Masha Allah. Which means you
have at least learned one verse.
What's Can You didn't raise your hand.
Can you say again, sir, please?
The master key for the hour.
You know, there are certain verses
of the Quran
which masha Allah you can even remember
them
by knowing their use. Sorry, I just got
confused, sir, because two of the verses
>> Come out of the confusion. Don't get
confused and don't confuse the others.
Surely. Just give me your
15 seconds just
15 seconds?
I just got confused. I got jumbled up.
Sorry for that. Okay.
Yes, your 15 seconds are up.
Allah says in Surah Al Imran
chapter number three
verse number 60.
Allahu Akbar.
So many hands raised.
Arsh
They had already learned these verses.
Yes.
I know it by heart, sir. I just
I don't know why.
I learned it. I know it memorized.
You need to strive more then.
It is Suratul Al Imran chapter three
verse number 64. Now, continue.
Surah Al Imran chapter number three
verse number 64.
Ta'alu ila kalimatin
Sorry.
>> [laughter]
>> Sorry. Sorry.
Ud'u ila sabili rabbika bil hikmah.
Hey.
You are asking for another thing. Sorry.
Which thing? Yeah, the key to
Okay, brother Arshi is quite eager to
answer the question. Can you please pass
on the mic to brother Arshi?
Assalam-o-Alaikum. Alaikum Assalam.
Please don't mind this, but uh
the master key is 3160.
But we can go for 364.
Uh, 3160 If Allah uh helps you, then
none can overcome you. If Allah forsakes
you, then who can help you after that?
Let the believers put their trust in
Allah. And 364 is Qul ya ahlal kitab
All right.
Mistake.
>> [laughter]
>> All right. Half the verse. Uh
I could continue With more mistakes.
With more mistakes.
>> [laughter]
>> But this is this Quran, so you have to
be careful.
No, while you are memorizing it, you can
make a mistake. Uh While you are
memorizing it, you
You can't make a mistake.
Ba'duna ba'din
Your hands are already raised.
Okay, insha Allah. We will not let you
make more mistakes in the Quran. But by
the way, brother Arshi, what you said
was Surah Al Imran chapter three verse
number 160 Yeah. is the master key for
success.
Okay. Master key [clears throat] for
success. Okay. That without Allah's help
you cannot succeed in anything. Correct.
Whether it be memorizing the Quranic
verses, whether it be giving dawah
or whether it be business
your school life, college life,
anywhere.
Master key for dawah
to invite the people on commonalities is
Suratul Al Imran chapter three verse
number 64.
And this has been told in many of the
speeches of Dr. Zakir Naik that the
master key for dawah
is Surah Al Imran chapter number three
verse number 64
which Farik will insha Allah give us the
verse. Farik.
Arsh, you need to strive more.
Both in Surah names as well as in the
Quranic verses.
Surah Al Imran chapter number three
verse number 64. Qul ya ahlal kitab Say,
O people of the book, ta'alu ila
kalimatin sawa'in baynana wa baynakum
Come to common terms as between us and
you.
Allahu na'budu illallah That we worship
none but one almighty God. Wala nushrika
bihi shay'a That we associate no
partners with him. Wala yattakhiza
ba'duna ba'dan arbaban min dunillah That
we erect not among ourselves lords and
patrons other than Allah. Fa intawallaw
If then they turn back, faqulu ashhadu
Say, "Be our witness bi'anna muslimun
That we are Muslims bowing our will to
Allah subhana wa ta'ala." Subhana Allah.
So, all the methodology
And in alhamdulillah, in the talk he is
even modulating more. Masha Allah.
But now he's just giving verses.
But I would rather say that learn with
modulation. You know, more impact.
You know, this homework is basically
helping you
to better your speech. Your Islamic
talks.
This homework nobody should think that
why am I being made to learn so many
verses?
These verses are so common
in your dawah talks in answering
questions to the most common questions,
common questions.
So, everywhere it's going to be of
extreme help to you
to make your dawah
more impactful, more powerful
and insha Allah giving you better
results. Insha Allah.
So, learn the way as he has done.
And I expect that next time
when I take the homework and none of you
are excused. Please don't get me wrong.
None of you are excused
including Arsh, including brother Yusuf.
Brother Imran masha Allah did a good
job, but only 10. The other two
remaining.
I didn't test all the verses, but with
the fluency which Farik said
insha Allah I hope that he knows all the
verses at least 90% accuracy. Insha
Allah. More than 90%. Insha Allah.
But even he will be included. That since
you did not prepare for today's homework
what you were supposed to give
insha Allah you're going to get another
set of verses
and next time when I take the homework,
it will be 12 sets plus whatever you are
going to get the homework today.
So, next time, our revision time would
again be extended.
And who is to be blamed?
Who is to be blamed?
Brother Kaleem.
He is to be blamed. He is extending.
Am I extending?
So, learn the verses
everyone
on the tip of your tongue with the
reference
with the Arabic, with the English.
And insha Allah we will try to wrap it
up quickly. But if
you would give me different percentages
of learning
number of verses you learned is less,
then
the session may extend and then you have
to wait back as well.
But I'm not going to let these 12 verses
are very, very important.
The first set of verses that which we
have given to you.
All are important.
But for your dawah talks, as a da'ee of
Islam these verses should be on the tip
of your tongue.
With the reference, with the Arabic and
the English. And if you want to excel
then the reference part Arabic part
English translation, part Arabic part
English translation. So, the next time
we meet on day three, insha Allah.
That is on Tuesday. Tomorrow is a
holiday.
So, you have
the entire night today
the full day tomorrow and the entire
night tomorrow. So, you have one day and
two nights. And insha Allah, you know,
we will talk about that when we talk
about Was Christ really crucified?
One day and two nights
you have with you.
Which means masha Allah you have how
many hours?
How many hours?
24 + 12 36.
So, you have 36 hours. Brother Atiq, you
can start making the calculation now.
Brother Firdaus, brother Ibrahim, in 36
hours
how many hours are you willing to give
to learn the Quran, the Kalam of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala?
15 minutes for a person to learn one
verse.
One verse with its English translation
and reference. You may take 30 minutes,
40 minutes.
Listen to the audio. And everyone
download the application of the audio of
the Quran, the recitation of the Quran,
and it will be helpful to you. So your
next homework is updated, though I'm
going to give you the homework now, but
your homework would include the 12 sets
of the Quranic verses
which are helpful for Dawah talks, plus
the Quranic sets of verses that which
you are going to be given today in the
homework.
Jazakallahu Khairan wa akhiru da'wana
alhamdulillah Rabbil Alameen. Stay in
your places. Inshallah, the homework
would be distributed and
we have
the English translation of the Quran as
was told by Dr. Zakir Naik in the
morning.
We have the Qurans to be distributed to
you.
So when you collect the copy of the
Quran, yesterday there were some of the
brothers who were complaining about
their books, their papers being
misplaced, their bags being stolen.
I consider the first person to be blamed
is yourself, that you were careless.
When you're careless about your
belongings, only then you misplace it.
The more you value the thing, the more
you will be careful about that thing.
So we are going to give you the copies
of the Quran.
The moment you receive it, the best is
on the front page write your name.
On the front page.
Not the cover page.
Open the cover page, then on the front
page write your name. Inshallah, I
believe two translations of the Quran,
one is Sahih International, the other
one is Abdullah Yusuf Ali, the green
copy.
This green copy, Inshallah,
complimentary from IRF to all the
participants.
Complimentary.
Abdullah Yusuf Ali.
The revised. And Sahih International.
The second best two translations,
English translations of the Quran, and
plus
a set of books on Islamic knowledge.
So Inshallah, in future when you have to
prepare your own speeches, so Inshallah,
these books which are going to be given
to you as a complimentary gift would
Inshallah be very much beneficial and
helpful to you to prepare your lectures.
And these two translations of the Quran,
one is Abdullah Yusuf Ali and the other
one is Sahih International will also
help you to include the relevant Quranic
verses into your talks.
So with this we conclude and we request
everyone to be seated the while the
homework is being given. Okay,
Inshallah, I would myself distribute the
homework to you, so please be seated.
Jazakallahu Khairan wa akhiru da'wana
alhamdulillah Rabbil Alameen.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.